i played robbie mercer
[Music]
i was stabbed in the back and the
stomach by ghost face himself
because i was too distracted looking at
my phone watching my own live stream
and i tried to get out of the murder by
confessing that i was gay
because by robbie's theory if you're gay
your survivor horror movie which we all
know is not true
but if there's a life lesson to take out
of it it's you know get off your phone
pay attention to the world around you
you never know what may happen
[Music]
if robbie were still alive today he
would be one of the
biggest social media influencers out
there you would be on facebook
tick tock instagram i mean he was ahead
of the game with the whole live
streaming thing
so he would have millions of followers
driving his
lime green lamborghini that or maybe
become
a horror movie director maybe something
autobiographical based on his experience
either way he would turn his experience
into a cash cow somehow
my favorite treat from kraft will always
be an ice cold can of coke
for breakfast in the morning in the
afternoon
does not matter it's always a treat
baton with scream they would
put out a candy tray in the afternoon so
i would take a few
chocolate almonds
[Music]